so you all have a lot of fun as the
judges so what's going on right here
though this is pretty special
right here let's
get it get it look at the steps the
around the
yeah i'm good look at that tourney
that's a word
you know i i just want to say that i'm
making it look effortless but a lot of
work goes into that
okay i'm aware heidi my best friend
heidi
is always she doesn't sit still she's
got the energy of a five-year-old
and she said and i was commenting on the
fact that you know
she's i can't imagine what it's like to
walk in heels
yeah she goes try these on i go how can
i you know and she
it turns out that heidi klum has huge
feet well she's
so you know what that means anyway
[Laughter]
she said try these on and i'll show you
how to be a runway model
and uh how can you say no to heidi klum
yeah so i got to tell you it's not one
of my proudest moments
but it is uh forever on videotape and
you're showing it
thank god i'm married i'm not in the
dating scene any long
any longer and if i was this little clip
would get me out of it
oh well or you never know who might show
up or swap rat or whatever way you're
supposed to swap i don't know which way
you're supposed to swipe
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever